but I wasn't aware that I was crossing
the line between addiction and
independency addiction and independency
there is a difference between addiction
and independency and so far as addiction
is more of a towards movement we'll go
out of our way to try and find something
right dependence is I can't function
this I have this thing and cannabis did
become like that for me it become so
frequent using it every day sometimes
smoking it before school when I was at
that age and I genuinely didn't feel
like I could function without it
obviously I could but at the time
psychologically I need this stuff in
order to function so kind of cross the
line between addiction and move towards
dependence at that point in time